die spd lädt zum großen debatten camp
also wie 2016 und wie 2013
ich bin gespannt mit welchen neuen ideen
die sozen auch die nächste wahl
verlieren
warum sind sie denn heute hier ja
prinzipiell um unsere zukunft zu formen
ich meine darum geht es doch auf dem
größten politische
diskussionsveranstaltung des events das
ist bisher in europa gerettet
die etwas los also hier wird nach vorne
diskutiert und viele junge leute aus
ganz deutschland sind hier das ist schon
nicht schlecht um die coole location
hatten wir auch noch nicht so in der
folge warum hat unsere spd nicht zu
diesem massaker
fünf jahre hatten die zeit die man das
betäubungslose kastrieren von ferkeln
jahre hatten die schweine meister zeit
das zu ändern
wieder nicht zwei jahre und das ist
wirklich furchtbar was die ferkel da ich
mache die spd das ja weil sie in der
großen koalition selbstständig
betäubungslos kastriert wird das problem
ist dass das richtig weh tut
[Applaus]
hoffnung und liebe genossen
wir sind nicht die eierlegende
wollmilchsau die es jedem recht machen
kann sondern sollen sagen dafür stehen
wir uns dafür unterstützt ist willkommen
die es ja eher die eierlegende
wollmilchsau die ist der union in der
gruppe recht macht ja lager war gut oder
gut
das ist mir ganz spontan eingefangen
wird ich glaube dass der unterschied zur
spd dass mir manchmal spontan gute ideen
kommt und seht ihr die ganze zeitung
haben der leidenschaftlich sein gesehen
hat wird die leute mitreißt das sind sie
in ihren fragen werden ja auch immer
sehr leidenschaftlich
bitte jetzt haben sie mir aber den gag
kaputt gemacht ich wollte so an ihnen
runter gucken und sagen kennen sie da
jemanden ja ich kenne jemanden ganz
viele her fast jeden glaube ich oder
wahrscheinlich alle mich zum beispiel
auch das würden sie herrn scholz sagen
was würde ich ihnen sagen ich weiß gar
nicht was ich ihm sagen würde ich hatte
erst überlegt ob ich mir eine ein
autogramm von den hole aber dann hab ich
doch mich anders entschieden
das will man doch nicht los
[Musik]
es geht darum dass wir ideen entwickeln
es geht darum dass wir diese ent denen
blitze auch endlich zur sacharbeit
umsetzen wenn man könnte uns auch selber
laden sah es bei den umsätzen wenn da
was rauskommen soll muss dann am ende
aber auch wir sind paar ausrufezeichen
kommen was wir wollen
das hoffe ich das war letztes mal ja
auch so und hat sich was getan das weiß
ich nicht ob es das letzte mal war ich
glaube wir haben schon was ganz gucken
sie mal 2016 zukunftskongress die top
fünf gute bildung gerichte rente und
soziale sicherheit
bemerken sie selber das heißt sie von
andrea nahles
sie arbeitet hart und sagt wir schaffen
ist dann schaffen wir das
das ist einfach mal zu jemandem gehen
und den mitreißen richtig für die spd ja
wir beide zusammen kennen wir ja hier zb
hallo wir suchen leute wenn sie uns
schon kaufen die leute weg dann suchen
wir weiter
auch energiegeladen hier ja wohl und bin
mir jetzt hier zusammen
wir müssen unser neuer anderen müssen
über hunt kommt ja alte energie oder an
der positiven ausstrahlung tatsächlich
you here today german social demo car to
something that more fucked up plan your
country
aber sie haben darüber gelacht
so soll es bis dahin gibt es noch liegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verstörende szenen bei der
sozialdemokratie hier
ich muss jetzt erstmal duschen
[Musik]